episode 4 features some of the biggest
reveals and peacemakers so far will
white dragon armor up for a big cgi
heavy finale will vigilante ever find
acceptance and what's mern's ultimate
goal anyway
towards the end of episode 4 peacemaker
has a heart to heart with harcourt in
the same bar where the two chatted in
episode 1. after noting that lyota knew
about his difficult upbringing
peacemaker inquires about his file
harcourt eventually admits that
peacemaker's file says that white dragon
trained him to kill from a very young
age and that peacemaker was involved in
his own brother's mysterious death
peacemaker it's clearly disturbed that
his friends have such intimate knowledge
of one of his worst memories returning
home peacemaker lights up a bong and
dances while house of pain by faster
pussycat plays in his trailer sadly the
music appears to be a limited comfort to
the emotionally scarred superhero a
series of flashbacks show a
mullet-wearing white dragon forcing a
young peacemaker to kill a man tied to a
chair as peacemaker also remembers
killing rick flagging the suicide squad
he collapses to the ground where eagley
and goff study him as he mourns the loss
of his brother many decades earlier no
doubt we'll find out exactly who's
responsible for his brother's death in a
future episode
episode 4 is where we see leota's
natural ability as an intelligence
officer shine because white dragon has
become such a haunting force in
peacemaker's life lyota subtly suggests
that vigilante murder the white
supremacist leader her skill at
manipulating vigilante to do her bidding
is markedly reminiscent of that of her
mother amanda waller however lyot's
skills go well beyond the manipulation
of a psychopath like vigilante upon
returning to the team's headquarters
lyota and peacemaker discover that judo
master has escaped incapacitating john
economos and is on the run peacemaker
engages judo master in a fight but the
martial arts master is suddenly gunned
down by lyota while lyoto is unable to
pull the trigger on a former secret
service agent in episode 3 the lectures
from harcourt appeared to be making a
difference in her willingness to kill
sure
ignore your god-given natural talent we
have to imagine her mother would be
pleased by this development as the
episode comes to a close leota is seen
working late at the team headquarters
when she suddenly recognizes the logo of
a bottling company named glantai on a
bulletin board from the home of senator
royland garf searching through the
contents of annie striphausen's purse
she finds an access card for the same
business there's no doubt this business
is connected to the butterflies
episode 4 is making something clear
however vile and hateful peacemaker's
father may be white dragon is no fall
early on in the episode peacemaker
retrieves a number of helmets built by
his father and explains the vigilante
what his father's closet actually is
it's a quantum unfolding storage area it
leads to a dimensional nodule outside
normal space well i guess your dad's
pretty brainy for a racist to make a
place like this
later after succumbing to lyota's
manipulation vigilante attempts to goad
white dragon into attacking him though
his fellow white supremacists follow the
bait hook line and sinker white dragon
quickly sees through the ploy and
insists that he talk with detective
sophie song while he has previously made
his hatred for his son abundantly clear
white dragon's next moves are sure to
even further complicate their
relationship we have to imagine that his
army of white supremacists aren't going
to take too kindly to vigilante's
attempts to murder him especially given
his assumption that peacemaker
orchestrated it not to mention would be
very surprised if his super villain
costume doesn't get some use in the
finale
around the same time that vigilante is
released from prison mern sits in his
apartment watching the laughing gas
scene from lethal weapon 4. however the
task force captain appears entirely
emotionless while watching instead of
feasting on a bowl of popcorn mern is
revealed to be eating the same amber
fluid found at the home of the
butterflies the revelation that mern is
actually a butterfly is certainly
surprising but it also makes a lot of
sense in the context of previous events
in episode 3 murn admits to economos
that he is saddened by the things he has
done in the past but doesn't go into
detail about how he came to be
remorseful and also doesn't appear to be
overly emotional about it oddly he knows
that it is the first time he's ever
shared a feeling with anyone
come on you've never shared any feeling
nope
like you've never even said oh my god
i'm hungry
no
later when peacemaker describes the
purple trunks coming out of the mouths
of the goff family mern doesn't hesitate
in delivering an order to assassinate
the senator his wife and their two
children men's butterfly status also
makes this moment from early in episode
4 highly suspect my dad man jesus
dad i did i wasn't created in a petri
dish
while mern's exact paternal origins
remain a mystery at this point a petri
dish no longer sounds as unlikely as it
did before every episode of peacemaker
ends with a post-credits scene that
expands on another scene from the
episode that just finished airing
episode 4 ends with a return to white
dragon's quantum unfolding storage area
where peacemaker argues with vigilante
over the troubling connection between
peacemaker's mission and his father's
overt racism in the original scene
peacemaker is angry when vigilante
proclaims that
if it walks like a duck it's either a
duck or a duck wearing some type of
human costume peacemaker insists that
couldn't work noting
a duck in a human costume the sizes are
completely incompatible
while he points us out in the original
scene he goes on at length about it in
the extended edition you've had a lot of
stupid ideas but a duck in a human
costume
that's the stupidest idea you've ever
had and it's offensive to me
because i have a soul
this definitely seems like a wink-wink
moment from james gunn considering that
the size difference between humans and
butterflies is clearly not an obstacle
to their human disguises new episodes of
peacemaker drop on hbo max every
thursday check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about peacemaker are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]